Microsoft's 13.5 inch surface laptop 3
hasn't changed much since last year but
a few things that did change were
definitely for the better before I get
into those updates like the brand new
Intel 10th gen isolate processor as well
as the downsides of the surface laptop 3
let's talk about what I really like
about this laptop we've got the $1,300
model in black which now comes with a
metal finish all the way around compared
to last year's black surface to which
came with a dark grey soft touch
Alcantara finish on the palm rest so now
you get black metal literally everywhere
and it's probably the cleanest laptop
design I've ever seen from the bottom of
the laptop which lacks extra events
stickers or visible screws to the top
which has a very simple and minimalistic
Microsoft logo and of course the display
in palm rest which lack logos in that
annoying intel sticker that comes on a
lot of Windows laptops I've honestly got
to say that this is one of the most
minimalistic laptops I've ever seen and
absolutely love that about it the switch
from Alcantara to metal on the palm rest
actually makes a huge difference in how
premium thus laptop feels and in my
opinion definitely worth the $300
upgrade since you also get double the
storage the only thing I don't like
about the black finish is that dust and
oily fingerprints are much more visible
but thanks to the metal finish is very
easy to clean whereas the Alcantara
finish was pretty easy to stain and
quite hard to get clean the overall
build quality and solidness of the
surface 3 laptop was rivaled only by
Dells most recent XPS 2 and one that we
recently reviewed be sure to check that
out at the end of this video if you
haven't already
just like the surface 2 we get a really
good display for the price with more
than enough resolution an awesome 3 by 2
aspect ratio that's great for browsing
the web very decent 97 percent srgb
color accuracy and touch screen support
the displays peak brightness also
reaches 400 nits which is actually
really good but my biggest gripe is that
the display is quite reflective so you
almost feel like you have to use it at
maximum brightness in a well-lit room
now
one of my favorite things about this
laptop is Windows hello facial
recognition which instantly logs you in
as soon as you open it it just doesn't
get any more convenient than that and
the keyboard is basically as traditional
as it gets and was very easy to
accurately type on it just doesn't feel
as great as some other laptops like the
pics of a go and XPS 13 two and one it
feels like it's lacking a bit of spring
after you press down but it's still
decent overall on the plus side I
actually really like the surface laptop
breeze quiet and responsive trackpad
quite a bit better than the pretty loud
and clicky trackpad of the XPS so I'd
rate it as one of the best Windows
trackpads especially for its larger than
usual size another thing that really
impressed me was the speaker quality now
if you're trying to find the speaker
grilles on the surface laptop three you
won't find them because the speakers are
actually beneath the keyboard and to our
surprise they actually sound great
they're not only louder and have better
sound quality than the ones on the new
XPS 13 two and one but they're actually
a bit louder than a comparable 2019
13-inch MacBook Pro
[Music]
I'd honestly have to say that these are
the best speakers we've heard on a
13-inch Windows laptop in more than good
enough for streaming shows and movies so
kudos to Microsoft for that now with all
that being said let's get into the big
changes we're seeing this year I'll get
into the new processor in a second but I
want to first mention the changes in
ports we're still getting a full-size
USB a port for those legacy connections
which is always nice to have along with
the standard headphone jack and the Mac
safe style charging port that will
instantly disconnect if someone trips
over the cable which gives you some
extra peace of mind the main change this
year is the switch from a mini
DisplayPort which is honestly pretty
useless to me to a much more usable USB
C port especially now that it's starting
to become more common the biggest
downside I see here is that the USB C
port doesn't support Thunderbolt 3 and
even the highest end model doesn't
support it either so that means you
can't connect an e GPU or get a high
bandwidth connection to an external
monitor or external docks now if you
don't know what Thunderbolt 3 is forget
about it you'll love this laptop but if
you do and it actually matters to you
you might want to look elsewhere now
let's talk about the biggest change
we're getting this year and that's the
switch from Intel's H n processors to
the brand-new 10th gen ice Lake CPUs
there are quite a few benefits with this
first off we get better connection specs
like Bluetooth 5 and integrated Wi-Fi 6
along with even faster lpddr4 X Ram
ice Lake is also using the brand new 10
nanometer architecture so it's going to
be more efficient using less power in
staying cooler compared to before but
along with that we're actually seeing a
seriously great jump in performance
we're seeing almost twice the single
core score compared to the surface
laptop 2 and in almost 70% faster
multi-core score it really just doesn't
get much better than this especially
since you still get this chip at the
base $1000 price into our surprise it
even outperformed the base $1300 13 inch
MacBook Pro so the surface laptop 3 is
definitely not a slouch in the
performance Department this year it also
gets Intel's improved iris plus graphics
compared to the standard UHD graphics
that we got last year giving us a really
impressive
OpenCL score as well all in all there
are just two things I would really want
Microsoft to change for next year the
addition of thunderbolt three and a
display that's either a bit brighter or
less reflective and maybe just a little
bit more color accurate to get it up to
100% srgb other than that I'm really
happy with the surface laptop 3 overall
the one thing that may keep you from
buying it is the price at a base price
of $1,000 and $1,300 for the premium
all-metal finish it's quite a bit more
expensive than other Windows laptops but
it's saving grace is the premium build
quality clean design decent display
excellent speakers awesome trackpad and
of course the incredible performance
this laptop will basically cover all the
bases doing things that people do on a
daily basis extremely well and it's also
capable of doing some of the more heavy
tasks like photo and video editing every
now and then albeit not as well as some
of the other laptops with dedicated
graphics cards I'd recommend the 13.5
inch surface laptop 3 to anyone who
wants to spend up to $1,300 on a premium
Windows laptop you won't really get much
more value by upgrading to get more
storage or RAM since it's still lacking
Thunderbolt 3 but the base model is
actually a pretty great deal for what
you get if you want to see us compare
the surface laptop 3 to the 13-inch base
macbook pro you can check that video
right over there and if you enjoy this
review click that circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]